So the big news that broke late Friday is
that indeed, Twitter has banned Donald Trump
permanently from its platform.
We're going to go through the decision that
Twitter made and then talk about the implications.
Twitter putting out a statement saying after
close review of recent tweets from the Trump
account and the context around them, specifically
how they're being received and interpreted
on and off Twitter, we have permanently suspended
the account due to the risk of further incitement
of violence in the context of horrific events
this week.
We made it clear on Wednesday that additional
violations of the Twitter rules would potentially
result in this very course of action.
Our public interest framework exists to enable
the public to hear from elected officials
and world leaders directly.
It is built on a principle that the people
have a right to hold power to the account
to account in the open.
However, we made it clear going back years
that these accounts are not above our rules
entirely and cannot use Twitter to incite
violence.
Among other things, we will continue to be
transparent around our policies and their
enforcement.
Now, reportedly when this happened, the word
being used is ballistic.
Trump went ballistic at the White House when
he was banned from Twitter.
A senior administration said that when Twitter
permanently took down Trump's account, Trump
was scrambling, trying to figure out what
to do.
Initially, Trump started tweeting through
the official Perdis account.
Now, the Perdis account is an account that
is in the hands of whoever is president.
So it's not Trump's account.
It's Trump has access to it while being president
that has been shut down.
Trump then tried tweeting through one of his
aides or staffers that was shut down.
And the president reportedly running around
the White House going absolutely crazy.
The White House then put out a statement saying
Trump is negotiating with other sites and
looking at building his own platform and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So there's a there's a number of different
important things we have to talk about here.
First of all, there's lots of really bad arguments
being made by people on the right and people
on the left, including that Twitter shouldn't
be allowed to do this either because they
are silencing only right wing voices, which
is untrue, or because Trump is president of
the United States.
The guidelines are already a lower bar for
world leaders, Twitter has said, and it was
even implicit in the statement they put out.
Twitter has said that when one is a world
leader, they air on the side of not taking
content down and not banning because they've
determined, and I agree with their determination
that it is important for us to know what world
leaders are saying.
However, we would expect our elected officials
to be held to a higher standard than the average
Twitter user with two followers sending me
hate tweets.
Right.
Like in other words, it's counterintuitive
that world leaders, some of the most powerful
people in the world, get held to an even lower
standard merely because they are world leaders.
That's been the case all along.
Twitter is a business that is allowed to have
terms of service and they're allowed to enforce
it.
But consider the greater hypocrisy that many
on the right are now essentially arguing Americans
have an inalienable right to be able to tweet
any limitation on their ability to tweet is
unconstitutional.
It's a violation of rights granted by God.
The Constitution, who knows?
And by the way, there's no right to health
care.
Health care is a product that should be bought
and sold on the free market if you can afford
it.
But you cannot be restricted in your ability
to tweet.
Give me a break, guys.
These people have been pathetic for a very
long time.
Don Jr. then coming out and saying, whoa,
we have to do something about the market monopoly
power of Twitter.
Where are we on antitrust?
Well, look at your dad.
I have been out there for years saying we
are not and we've done.
Multiple interviews, we are not dealing seriously.
With the antitrust law that we have and we
have not enforced it, I've been talking about
that for years, but all of a sudden, the day
Trump's banned from Twitter, Don Jr. cares
about monopoly power.
Give me a break, guys.
So the truth is, Trump's account should have
been removed long ago.
There should be a higher standard on elected
officials, not a lower standard.
And Trump got away with this long.
But now there is sort of this deluge.
There's for lack of a better term, these massive
dumps of bans and suspensions that are coming
now since the riotous insurrection.
Now a cautionary message, despite my belief
that this is the right thing to do based on
Trump's use of Twitter and incitement to violence
and defense of the rioters, despite the fact
that we're saying it was correct to ban Trump
12 days before he leaves office forever.
This is a sign of how much we've failed as
a country over the last four years to control
Donald Trump and to hold accountable the people
who defended him.
The rats leaving the sinking ship.
Now, Betsy Davos, William Barr, Republican
Senator Pat Toomey, who now says Trump should
go.
Chris Christie, who now says Trump should
be impeached.
They are right.
Yes, sure.
But we're 12, 11, 10 now, nine days out as
they are doing these things.
They do not deserve to have their images rehabilitated.
And we're going to talk about that after the
break.
But we will have more coverage of the Trump
Twitter ban and social media implications
on our Instagram, where you can find us at
David Pakman show.
And you can find me on Instagram as well at
David Pakman,